- [Instructor] Let's say
we wanted to figure out
what one half minus one third is equal to.
And we can visualize
each of these fractions.
One half could look like
that where if I take a whole
and if I divide it into
two equal sections,
one of those two equal
sections would be a half
and you see that shaded in green here.
And then from that, we're
trying to subtract a third
and we can visualize a third this way.
That if this whole thing is a whole,
I divide it into three equal sections
and one of those three
equal sections is a third.
So what we wanna do is
take away this gray box
from this green box and figure out
how we can mathematically
say what is left over.
So pause this video and see
if you can have a go at this.
And I'll give you a
hint, it will be useful
to be able to represent
your halves and thirds
in terms of a different denominator.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So the way that we can approach this is
to get a common denominator.
If I can express both fractions
in terms of the same denominator,
it's going to be a lot easier to subtract.
And the common denominator
that's most useful
is to find the least common denominator.
And the smallest number
that is both a multiple of two and three
is actually two times three, or six.
So what if we were to
write each of these numbers
in terms of sixths.
So how can we rewrite one
half in terms of sixths?
I always have trouble saying that.
Well if I start with one
half and if I multiply
the denominator by three,
that's going to get us to sixths
and so I don't change the
value of the fraction.
I need to multiply the
numerator by three as well.
As long as I multiply both the numerator
and the denominator by the same thing.
Well, then that's still
going to be equal to one half
and you can visualize
what that looks like.
If you take each of
these two equal sections
and turn them into three equal sections,
well then you're gonna have
a total of six equal sections
or sixths.
Two times three in the denominator
and the part that was shaded in in green
which was just one of those sections
is now three times as many sections.
So your one half is now
equal to three over six.
And we can do the same thing over here.
If we start with one third
how do we express it in terms of sixths?
Well to go from three to six
I would multiply it by two,
and so I also wanna do
that in the numerator
so that I don't change
the value of the fraction
and we can visualize that.
Notice, if you take all three sections
and you turn each of
them into two sections
you now have six equal sections.
So you are now dealing with sixths,
and that one section before
is now going to become two sections.
So this is now going to
be equal to two sixths.
So we can actually rewrite things as
this is the same thing as
three sixths minus, minus two sixths.
And what do you think that is going to be?
Well if I have three of something
and I subtract two of them away
I'm going to be left with
one of that something.
So I'm going to be left
with one sixth in this case.
And we can visualize it just the way
we visualized everything else.
If you take two of these gray bars
or two of these sections
from these three sections
you're just going to be
left with one of them.
This is one of the six equal sections.